avec plus de 7 milliards d'habitants sur
son sol la planète atteint aujourd'hui
ses limite chaque année nous consommons
l'équivalent d'une planète et
demi les scientifiques nous ont averti
si nous continuons dans cette voie la
consommation énergétique mondiale
devrait augmenter de 56 % d'ici à
2040 le message est passé qu'il y avait
un risque important de changement clim
qui qui aurait des conséquences très
graves demain s'élèvera jour après jour
le premier barrage en terre d'Europe
depuis plus de 100 ans de grandes
infrastructures de barrage ont vu le
jour l'utilisation de l'hydroélectricité
s'est développé parallèlement les hommes
consomment du pétrole et du charbon en
partie responsable de l'augmentation des
gaz à effet de
serre aujourd'hui la donne a changé et
les états prennent conscience de la
nécessité d'une
transition l'Union européenne souhaite
que l'énergie soit produite à 20 % par
les énergies renouvelables à l'horizon
2020 on a du mal à imaginer à quel point
notre vie tous les jours elle est
complètement dictée par le
climat l'augmentation du niveau des
océans et des températures entraînerait
des changements
irréversibles des milliers d'espèces
seraient voué à
disparaître notre société et nos villes
deviendrai quant à ell
inhabitaable l'objectif visé est de
produire 50 % d'énergie verte d'ici à
2050 grâce au photovoltaïque à l'éolien
ou encore à la
biomasse collectivité local association
et constructeurs se sont alliés pour
développer une autre technologie
l'hydrolien ni plus ni moins qu'une
éolienne allongé dans l'eau une
hydrolienne est une énergie discrète qui
produit de l'électricité de façon
constante grâce aux courants émaré
prévisible des décennies en
avance pouvant mesurer de 5 à 20 m de
haut cette machine s'adapte aux fleuves
aux estuaires et aux
océans au fil de l'eau vous allez
découvrir quatre villes en métropole qui
ont fait le pari de tester l'hydrolien
pour se hisser à la pointe de la
[Musique]
bienvenue à Bordeaux Orléan pint Paul
bra et l'île
dououessant et si l'hydrolien était la
technologie de
[Musique]
demain
la France est le deuxème gisement
européen en matière d'hydroélectricité
marine avec 9000 km de littorau et 3000
km de fleuve l'hydrolien trouve toute sa
place sur le territoire
français aujourd'hui il existe deux
sites prometteurs le r Blanchard en
Normandie et le fromver en Bretagne
à2 il représenteraiit la production de 3
à 5 réacteurs
nucléaires dans les zones insulaires les
hydroliennes offrent un intérêt tout
particulier car elles permettent de
remplacer la combustion d'énergie
fossile à la fois coûteuse et
polluante
[Musique]
wessan surnommé l'île du bout du monde
et situé à 20 km des côtes du
finisterère avec ses falaises ciselées
par la mer d'roise ses prairies et ses
moutons difficile de croire que le
territoire accueillera demain la
première hydrolienne reliée au réseau
national depuis quelques années
les 880 habitants ont vu leur vie
insulaire bousculer par l'arrivée d'un
projet de grande ampleur dirigé par une
petite entreprise quimpéroise
Sabella l'île accueillera bientôt une
hydrolienne haute de 17 m soit
l'équivalent d'un immeuble de 5
étages son immersion se fera dans le
courant du fromver à 2 km des côtes car
le fromver situé entre l'île dououessant
et de Moline et le courant marin le plus
fort
d'Europe jusqu'à maintenant
l'électricité était fournie grâce à une
centrale thermique consommant près de 2
millions de litres de foule par an et
dont le prix est bien plus élevé que sur
le continent la sele hydrolienne
permettra d'alimenter un quart des
habitants l'objectif serait donc
d'assurer à terme la totalité des
besoins
énergétiques Dony palu est professeur
des écoles mais aussi et surtout maire
d'ouisant depuis
1995 ils nous ont contacté il y a déjà
un paquet d'années en disant en nous
demandant si sur le principe on était
favorable puisqu'il y a un site qui s'y
prête ici qui est le courant du from
faut dire aussi que dans l'acceptation
par la par la municipalité la population
c'est aussi la démarche de l'entreprise
qui n'est pas du tout arrivé en terrain
conquis qui nous a contacté en amont et
vraiment qui a fait un gros travail pour
que ce projet puisse être accepté mais
aussi adopté par les gens c'estàd que
les gens sentent aussi que ça soit un
projet douesent même si évidemment c'est
l'industriel qui qui est au commande
c'estd de retirer uniquement la partie
turb Sabella a régulièrement organisé
des réunions publiques invitant les
habitants à venir poser leurs questions
et parler de leurs craintes un moyen
supplémentaire d'intégrer les wtin à ce
projet de longue haline soulève la
machine en utilisant deux grues comme ça
ça leur permet d'orienter la machine
très précisément évidemment on a
consciance aussi que comme partout le
fiel ça ne sera pas inépuisable et qu'il
faut trouver d'autres solutions alors il
y Ava eu des expérimentations il y a 30
ans avec des éoliennes al la première
était tombée la deuxième n'a jamais
fonctionné alors c'est vrai que les gens
avaient un souvenir pas
trop pas trop positif des éoliennes même
si aujourd'hui évidemment les les
technologies ont évolué donc voilà je
pense que ça motivé aussi notre avis et
puis ça remet aussi peut-être au essens
sur les rails de du 21e siècle parce que
des des endroits touristiques comme les
nôtres avec un un passé riche je parlais
la marine marchande de cette vie dure au
19e début 20e ça fait une sorte de chape
de plomb où on nous enferme dans un
patrimoine qu'on voudrait figer je pense
que par des projets comme ça ben ou ça
on peut dire aussi que c'est une voilà
une terre qui peut se projeter dans des
nouvelles technologies et se projeter
vers l'avenir et être aussi une image
qui voilà qui nous ouvre des horizons
vers l'avenir plutôt que uniquement nous
nous enfermer dans ce cette espèce de
qu'on voudrait
figer l'aventure Sabella est à
l'initiative de Jean-François Davio
après plusieurs années de militantisme
il a réuni une douzaine de jeunes
ingénieurs autour de ce projet
hydrolien l'entreprise a dû soulever un
budget de 13 millions d'euros pour
réaliser entièrement cette machine
après-mi donc c'est à
14h c'est en janvier5 15 que la
construction de l'hydrolienne baptisée
D10 a enfin pu débuter sur le port de
commerce de Brest D10 dans notre jargon
ou D03 ou D15 d S diamètrre 10 et 10 m
en l'occurrence voilà donc le rotor fait
10 m de diamètre cette machine fait 1 MW
de puissance maximum et
puis une des fonctionnalités de ces
machines c'est de ne pas être renversé
par le courant donc il faut qu'elle soit
stable au fond posée au fond dimensionné
pour résister bien évidemment à des
tempêtes centenales donc on imagine la
plus forte tempête d'un siècle passer
sur cette machine sans qu'elle sans
qu'elle bouge sans qu'elle soit
[Musique]
détruite Sabella n'est pas le seul
maître à bord accompagné par différentes
structures l'entreprise profite du
savoir-faire et des connaissances de
différents corps de métiers elle veille
à ce que ce mastodonte a le moins
d'impact possible ces machines encore
une fois ne sont pas des machines à
faire des sushis voilà c'est des
machines qui on très lentement qui ont
tourner de l'ordre de 10 à 15 tours par
minute ce projet inscrit également un
protocole de suivi environnemental qui a
été défini conjointement avec le parc
mariniroise avec sonopolis avec premè et
cetera pour suivre un peu ce qui va se
passer autour de cette expérimentation
pour voir quelles peuvent être les
incidences environnementales que cette
machine pourrait induire qu'elle soit de
type acoustique accéentologie à la faune
par exemple il y en aura pas mais voilà
c'est encore faut-il le le prouver le
démontrer voilà donc c'est c'est des
projets qui vont per mettre à une toute
petite échelle c'est une seule machine
ici hein de valider une une suite avec
bien évidemment plus d'ampleur des
projets de plus d'ampleur tout en ne
faisant pas de bêtises il faut pas jouer
aux apprentis sorciers bien évidemment
on est parti pour une campagne d'essès
d'abord de d'environ une année pendant
lesquelles on va mesurer plein de choses
alors elle est bée de capteur donc on va
essayer de de mieux apprendre son
fonctionnement au rythme des marées au
rythme de la houle qui va passer dessus
on va regarder quelles sont ses
performances qu'est-ce qu'elle est
capable d'exporter en terme de de
production d'énergie quelle est la
qualité du signal électrique qui va être
produit cette machine ne fait pas de
dégâts sur les fond marins encore une
fois elle est juste posée donc le jour
où je dois la retirer j'enlève tout et
je laisse le site parfaitement en
état même si l'hydrolien semble être une
bonne alternative pour Jean-Louis dufine
chercheur au CNRS les énergies
renouvelables doivent être avant tout
complémentaires
le solaire il y a l'éolien donc le vent
il y a l'hydrolienne au mouvement d'eau
il y a les Mar matrices A l'hydraulique
il y a plein de choses qui qui se font
qui existent je pense que remplacer une
bonne partie de l'énergie actuelle par
de l'énergie renouvelable est possible
je pense pas que chacune d'elles puisse
apporter la solution mais mais
l'ensemble peut contribuer de façon
[Musique]
significative Yvon tradeek est goémonier
à l'ANIL dut depuis 25 ans il récolte
les algues dans le plus grand champ
d'algue d'Europe situé entre l'archipel
de Molen et
wessan ici les 15 bateaux récolte entre
50 et 55000 tonnes d'algues à l'année
pour le moment Yvon ne semble pas
affoler à la vue de l'immersion d'une
hydrolienne dans cette mer qu'il
considère comme son jardin qui nous
inquiète nous tant que guemounier c'est
pas vraiment l'hydrolienne où là où elle
est mise parce qu'elle est mise elle est
mise dans le from ce qui nous inquiète
le plus c'est plutôt le câble
qui qui dans le futur partira s'il y a
un champ un champ hydrulien à cet
endroit-là si on a un câble qui doit
rejoindre la côte le continent c'est
plutôt ce tracé là qui nous qui nous
inquiète puisque il passera forcément
sur sur les champ d'algue et nous
impactera directement le problème du câ
c'est que s'il est sur des fond meuble
il sera il sera ensouillé il sera il
sera mis dessous le problème c'est que
nous on récolte des alces sur des roches
et que là il est pas question d'enfouir
un câble sous les roches et donc
forcément il y aura une incompatibilité
de d'exploitation avec le câble et ça
veut dire pour nous enfin la crainte ça
veut dire des zones où on pourra plus
aller par exemple moi je pense que il
faut pas arrêter quelque chose avant
qu'on ait commencé ni avant qu'on ait
testé il faut il faut tester il faut
voir si ça marche si si c'est rentable
si c'est pas rentable quel est l'impact
et puis voilà et on avance pas à pas et
à chaque fois on voit on voit où on en
[Musique]
est onine main et marin pêcheur sur
l'île dououessant depuis plusieurs
années avec son mari ils ont choisi de
faire une pêche durable et à la ligne
leur devise pêchz moins mais pêcher
mieux on aura du lieu tous les jours et
ben demain on en aura avec l'avenue de
l'hydrolienne les appréhensions d'Ondine
grandissent la semaine on pourra en
avoir que ce soit implanté dans le
fromver qui est effectivement on le sait
un courant des parmi les plus violents
en Europe mais parmi les plus préservé
voilà c'est c'est là où on s'est dit que
que ça pouvait pas coller qu'on peut pas
faire un essai ici on est des veilleurs
en fait de la nature on est sur place
voilà 4 mois par an là-bas donc on voit
des choses s y a pas impact négatif
c'est ce qu'on espère fortement on trèit
bien mais s'il y en a un on va détruire
quelque chose que peut-être on n même
pas au courant détruire des espèces qui
habitaent là on connaissait pas
forcément ou et puis surtout c'est que
un courant c'est la source de la
vie si on a un impact à la base d'un
courant on fout en l'air une chaîne
trophique mais jusqu'au foc et l'homme
quoi donc en fait on vit on travaille
avec ces courants et et je trouve
qu'on c'est c'est dur de commencer à
tester quelque chose dans
un un endroit voilà source de
[Musique]
vie même si certains climatcepties n'y
croi pas le réchauffement climatique est
déjà en cours et un changement sans
précédent est annoncé Jean-Louis dufine
l'explique le réchauffement climatique
c'est le fait que la Terre se réchauffe
notamment dû à l'accroissement des gaz à
effet de serre par contre la terre ne
fait pas que se réchauffer à partir
moment où la terre se réchauffe vous
changez la circulation de l'atmosphère
vous changez les pluies les tempêtes ou
les ou les cyclones donc vous changez un
peu tout le climat la faune et la flore
seront modifié ça c'est à peu près
inéluctable la niche écologique de
l'espèce est petite si vous la modifiez
un peu l'espèce soit elle PE
m dispara il y vraiment un risque
très très
fort Sabella est encore loin d'une
possible ferme de 200
hydrolienes leur première machine doit
d'abord passer des tests avant d'être
embarqué pour le
from au même moment dans l'estuaire de
la
Gironde une machine plus modeste se
prépare
dans le plus vaste estuaire d'Europe de
nombreux paysages s'offrent aux
[Musique]
aququittins pour sauvegarder la beauté
de leur patrimoine le projet cineéo a vu
le jour à
Bordeaux le but est de proposer aux
industriels français et étrangers de
venir tester leur technologie
hydrolienne pour une durée de 6 à 18
mois sous le pont de pierre emblématique
de l'air napoléonienne de forts courants
se font ressentir un lieu idéal pour
plonger des hydroliennes fluviales et
estuariennes salut messieurs hydrotube
Energie est une petite entreprise
bordelaise qui s'est lancé dans
l'hydrolien on la repose sur la barge
elle fait partie
dujeto immerger sa propre machine
précise de la hauteur de la hauteurau
passionné par la mer et la Garonne Gilda
Gérard porte le projet depuis 3 ans il
est en charge de la partie mécanique de
l'hydrolienne baptisée H3 la Garonne
c'est un fleuve assez compliqué parce
qu'il est pas il est sauvage il est il
est soumis au cru il est soumis aux
marais qui viennent de de l'estuaire il
y a le mascaret ça charie énormément de
d'embacle les déchets flottants donc
cette Garonne est un excellent
laboratoire pour pour tester notre
machine dans de multiples conditions et
on se dit que et d'ailleurs c'est
l'objet du site cineo c'est que si notre
machine fonctionne sur la Garonne elle
fonctionnera partout où on la mettra
c'est une hydroliène fluviale donc elle
n'a rien de comparable à ce qu'on peut
trouver sur des hydroliennes marines
donc c'est une hydrolienne qui fait 10 m
de long 4,50 de large et qui est équipé
d'une hélice de 3,50 on l'a défini pour
qu'elle soit re juste fiable et qu'elle
puisse résister à un fleuve comme la
Garonne et puis dans le cas où on a une
crue trop important et bien on a la
possibilité de remonter notre turbine et
de la mettre à l'abri le temps que la
crue la crue se
passe le projet cineéo n'aurait pas pu
être réalisé sans énergie de la lune
tous originair d'akiten cette équipe
d'océanologue a créé ce bureau d'études
spécialisé dans l'environnement
océanographique et les énergies
renouvelable depuis 2009 Marc Lafosse
président de cette start-up bordelaise
se mobilise avec ses associés pour que
ce site d'essa puisse ouvrir au
constructeurs projet cnoo en fait est né
en en 2011 on en est le porteur
historique et on a voulu tout simplement
profiter des courants de la Garon que
l'on connaissait bien qu'on avait déjà
pas mal
investigué pour en faire unsite d'ESS à
ce moment-là la filière était encore
moins mature que maintenant et on s'est
dit que c'était intéressant de de
pouvoir essayer de mobiliser des acteurs
publics et privés pour financer ce site
de façon à à donner un coup de pouce à
cette filière industrielle en émergence
et on a pas mal de on va dire de
facilité sur ce site puisque la pêche
est interdite la pêche amateur est
professionnel que la navigation sur la
Garonne est pas très intense on a à peu
près trois quatre bateaux qui
franchissent le pont par jour ce qui est
pas ce pas comparable à d'autres
estuaires plus plus industriels tous les
jours on va pour se balader autour de l'
olen avec avec des capteurs depuis
depuis un bateau pour comprendre son
impact environnemental ensuite on va
maintenir en condition opérationnel tout
un tas de capteurs qui vont se être
positionnés aussi bien dans au niveau de
la machine que sur le câble ou que sur
son poste de conversion livraison donc
tous les jours on aura on aura une
équipe de techniciens et d'ingénieurs
qui vont travailler là-dessus de façon à
ce que le développeur une fois qu'il est
sorti de ce site d'essai et bien quelque
part il peut montrer patte blanche sur
ou pas sur son son impact
environnemental
[Musique]
nombreux sont les Girondins amateurs de
pêche au
Carl plus haut si les hydroliennes de
cineo venent à blesser les poissons au
cours de leur migration conséquen
pourrait s'en ressentir l'élce fait 3,50
de diamètre et les grilles protègent
jusqu'à 1,50 à peu près afin de les
rassurer frankck Jani le président
d'hydrotube ennergie a rendez-vous avec
les représentants de l'Association
Départementale des pêcheurs au filet la
question qui revient systématiquement
c'est est-ce que les poissons ne vont
pas être coupés en rondelle donc ce
qu'on explique de façon empirique
aujourd'hui c'est que ce n'est pas un
moteur qui entraîne leséliss mais c'est
bien le c'est bien l'eau et le courant
du fleuve qui entraîne l'éliss donc on
peut considérer que le poisson est dans
son élément et il voit bien qu'il y a
quelque chose un peu d'un peu
particulier devant lui si s'il en a peur
il va s'écarter en tant que pêcheur tant
qu'elle ne sera pas dans l'eau et
qu'elle sera pas opérationnelle on ne
peut pas encore se prononcer là-dessus
quoi c'est pas
possible pour le chercheur Jean-Louis
dufine l'augmentation des températures
n'est pas le seul effet observable du
changement climatique de façon très
schématique on va plutôt augmenter les
contrastes c'est-à-dire les endroits où
il pleut moins et ben on va avoir
tendance à moins pleuvoir et et le
contraire on va avoir des phénomènes
qu'on connaissait pas qui vont arriver
et de fait on Nura pas le tout le bagage
pour y
réagir bonsoir à tous record de chaleur
aujourd'hui sur toute la France le
thermomètre a frollé les 40 degrés dans
de nombreuses villes demain nouvel
épisode de picule annoncé ce qui risque
d'augmenter la pollution à l'ozone
enregistré dans le centre l'est le
sud-est et la région parisienne il y a
plein d'endroit du monde où il fait
chaud en été dans les villes d'accord et
puis quand on a la canicule de 2003
Paris ben on était pas habitué d'accord
c'est un événement qui arrivver là et
qu'on avait pas avant et donc finalement
si on regarde c'est s'il y a eu temps de
mort pourquoi c'est parce qu'on savait
pas quoi
faire sur le papier l'estuaire de la
Gironde jusqu'à Bordeaux pour pourrait
accueillir près de 300 machines mais le
projet cineo est un site test et aucune
hydroliène ne devrait être installé pour
une longue période dans le
fleuve si ce site figure déjà comme un
premier pas vers une production
d'énergie plus respectueuse de
l'environnement c'est à Orléan que la
toute première hydrolienne fluviale
française a été
plongée
[Musique]
dernier fleuve sauvage d'Europe la Loire
fascine elle dessine le lit protecteur
de nombreuses îles verdoyantes où l'on
trouve encore une nature exceptionnelle
et
[Musique]
préservée près du pont de l'Europe
caractéristique du centre-ville d'Orléan
une nouvelle habitante bâtie
hyrofluve est venu se glisser dans le
lit de la Loire en novembre
2014 un groupe du canoé kayak club or
Lesan vient troubler le calme apparent
de la
Loire tu prend la responsabilité du
grouendant les préparatifs le président
du
cluber guide du jour pour lui bonne
balade c'est l'occasion de partager une
passion on essaie de transmettre le
plaisir déjà parce que faire du kayak
c'est d'abord du plaisir voir la Loire
au ras de l'eau toucher l'eau sentir
parce que vous avez des parfums
différents voir au travers parce qu'elle
est transparente la Loire on voit VO le
fond de la Loire vous voyez les poissons
vous pouvez y voir des castors
éventuellement
d'abord curieux de voir cette drôle de
sirène dans la Loire le club a
finalement pu comprendre cette
technologie et adapter sa pratique une
nouvelle arrivante dans la Loire ça
implique forcément pour nous
déjà rechercher le maximum de précaution
et de sécurité savoir si le fait qu'un
hydrolienne s'implante en Loire pourrait
présenter un risque pour les personnes
qui pratiquent le ir au niveau du
kayak de ce côté-là donc on a été
entièrement rassuré puisque donc il n'y
a pas de courant d'eau qui sont
provoqués par courant spécifiqu d'eau
qui sont provoqués par l'hydrolène ça
nécessite pour nous simplement de
modifier un petit peu la
trajectoire les trisjectir qu'on utilise
et de pouvoir prévenir les personnes qui
navigueront sur la Loire les touristes
qui descendent la Loire l'été de bien
naviguer entre les deux obstacles qui
sont à cet
endroitl il y a 2 ans l'entreise prise
grenobloise hydroquest avait déjà plongé
une hydrolienne en milieu hostile au
cœur de
l'Amazonie aujourd'hui leur nouvelle
machine hydrofluve est testée à Orléan
selon des critères bien précis et ceux
durant 24 mois Jean-François Simon est
le président d'hydroquest l'hydrolienne
qui est là pèse une environ 12 tonnes
elle fait 12 m de long à peu près il
s'agit pas d'une machine qui est là pour
produire de l'électricité pour un client
comme vous acheteriez une machine une
voiture et cette voiture elle doit
fonctionner le premier jour c'est une
machine qui est à
l'essai une telle machine n'a pas
vocation à fournir les foyers français
en électricité hydroquest a pour
ambition d'exporter son hydrolienne pour
alimenter des villages isolés en Afrique
comme en Asie hydrolienne qui est qui
est là elle fait 40 kW de de puissance
nominale en France ça alimente à peu
près 75 personnes celle de 80 kW la
machine qui est à deux étages qui
ressemble très fortement à celle-ci
alimente 150 personnes à peu près en en
électricité résidentielle en
France par contre la même hydrolienne en
Afrique ou en Inde c'est 3000 personnes
et un parc de s hydroliennes ce qui est
une taille de parc tout à fait normal
c'est 300000 personnes 90
% du potentiel hydroélectrique de
l'Afrique n'est pas utilisé donc vous
avez un besoin vous avez des gisements
et voilà il faut
[Musique]
faire
Laur sont hydrobiologistes et écologues
ils travaillent pour Biotop un bureau
d'ingénierie chargé des opérations de
suivi écologique autour de
l'hydrolienne tous les jours ils
observent la faune et la flore du bord
de Loire à proximité de la machine et
étudie l'impact de l'hydrolienne sur
l'environnement
[Musique]
ouis ça chass en aval j'ai toujours
toujours aimé la nature toujours voulu
être au contact de la nature travailler
dehors faire des inventaires et je suis
dirigé tout naturellement vers vers le
bureau d'étude qui permet justement et
de travailler dehors et de travailler
sur des projets comme celui-ci qui qui
vont dans le bon sens donc l'objectif en
fait de ce matin c'était de suivre le le
comportement de la faune à proximité de
l'hydrolienne donc on observe à la
jumelle à la longue vue les les
différentes espèces d'oiseaux qui
peuvent être présente sur le sur le
secteur donc que ce soit les canards les
différentes espèces de de Stern les
cormants les lesérons les aigrettes pour
voir comment ell se déplace à proximité
de l'hydrolienne donc est-ce que c'est
une zone de chasse à proprement parler
est-ce qu'elle chasse plus loin plus en
Amond plus en aval est-ce qu'elle
fréquente la zone pour pour s'alimenter
ou ou simplement pour pour se déplacer
pour se
reposer
[Musique]
pour nous ce qui est intéressant c'est
justement d'être parti d'un suivi il y a
quelques quelques mois où les espèces
migratrices étaient pas encore arrivé et
de voir comment au cours de la saison
ben ces espèces ont pu s'approprier ce
nouvel élément donc d'abord elles
étaient peut-être un peu curieuses par
rapport à à cet élément et ensuite et
ben on se rend compte comme aujourd'hui
que ça chasse ça se déplace sans sans y
faire attention final
un peu de jus
qu en F fonction des résultats obtenus
les constructeurs sauront à quelle
distance les machines doivent être les
unes des autres pour réduire au maximum
leur impact aussi l'étude déterminera
combien de machines un site est capable
d'accueillir selon plusieurs critères
établis à Orléan comme sur l'île d'Ant
des réunions ont été organisées en
concertation avec la mairie
Stéphanie anton est adjointe au
développement durable elle a participé à
la sensibilisation des orléané à ce
projet notre but c'était vraiment les
informer et les sensibiliser de manière
ludique et pédagogique on va dire sur
les énergies renouvelabl et en même
temps de les impliquer dans ce projet là
les riverins ils avaient peut-être peur
d'une certaine pollution on va dire
visuelle alors finalement ils ont trouvé
que ça s'intégrait très bien dans le
paysage et pour les usagers ils avaient
peur par exemple les kquistes que ça les
êche justement de de pratiquer leur
activité sur la Loire ils sont aperçu
que justement c'était dans une démarche
proactive et qu'on voulait développer
les énergies renouvelable et que c'était
dans le bon sens après il y a toujours
les les réfractaires ça c'est sûr c'est
les plus plus difficiles à convaincre
mais donc là faut essayer de tourner
autrement le discours et faire le lien
justement avec avec leur santé parce que
la santé quand même c'est
primordial Bernard Rousseau fait
justement partie de ses réfractaires
ancien président de France Nature
Environnement il craint des
répercussions irréversible sur la faune
d'eau douce j'ai une sensibilité dès
l'enfance aux rivières à la Loire et
donc là on pouvait observer tout enfant
j'observais moi la la biodiversité
toutes les espèces et quand je fais une
comparaison avec ce que je peux observer
maintenant je me rends compte que c'est
un vrai désastre chaque fois que l'on
fait un ouvrage en en rivière ou dans un
cour d'eau et bien on va affecter la
circulation de ces poissons migrateur
alors maintenant il y a une autre
question fondamentale est-ce que le jeu
en vaut la chandelle est-ce que
l'investissement en veut en vaut la
chandelle dans la mesure où peut coûter
très cher et que ces hydroliennes en
rivière ont une faible puissance très
faible puissance euh et donc la
tentation pourrait être grande d'en
mettre plusieurs c'est pas parce qu' on
fait une 10 hydolè une centaine
d'hydroliènne que l'on va supprimer les
centrales nucléaires qui sont audessus
ou en dessous
faut faut arrêter de rêver et et et de
de se prendre les pieds dans le tapis là
si je peux dire le nucléaire il est là
alors je fais pas je ne milite pas pour
ce pour cette ce type d'énergie mais il
est installé et attention au fausses
solution c'est-à-dire que les
hydroliennes n'apporteront rien alors en
[Musique]
rivière si les hydroliennes fluviales ne
trouvent pas leur place en France elle
serait pourtant une solution ingénieuse
pour les pays en
développement bien que les prototypes
coûtent cher à réaliser l'investissement
financier est incontournable comme
l'explique Jean-Louis dufine toutes
cette technologie là il y a il y a
toujours des époques de maturation et
c'est c'est pas c'est c'est c'est
souvent plusieurs années même plusieurs
dizaines d'années hein quand vous
investissez par exemple pour l'économie
d'énergie vous vous payez aujourd'hui ce
que vous payerez pas dans le futur
d'accord c'est que quand on on paye pour
isoler une maison et ben on paye le
c'est comme on paye le fait qu'on
chauffera moins pendant 15 ans et donc
c'est une grosse masse d'argent qu'il
faut investir ça veut pas dire que c'est
pas rentable ça veut dire que un moment
donné il faut
[Musique]
investir le potentiel fluvial est donc
bien moindre que le potentiel marin dans
les pays développés comme la France mais
avant de pouvoir choisir les sites
d'implantation les plus appropriés les
146 technologies hydroliennes recensées
dans le monde restent à
[Musique]
tester sur le site de pimpul Bréa les
tests sont presque terminés et deux
hydroliennes devraient être relié au
réseau national avant la fin de
[Musique]
l'année au large des côtes d'armor à 8
km de la pointe de l'arcest se trouve
l'île de
Bréa grâce à son microclimat ce bout de
terre développe des plantes et fleurs
diversifiées ce qui lui a valu le surnom
de l'Î au
fleurs en 2006 Véronique badaille et
Vincent son mari ont adopté une manière
de vivre plus respectueuse de
l'environnement tu veux que je t'aide
ouais et ben tu n'aura pas de chiseau
on avait avec mon mari un vieux vieux
rêve de gosse de de venir s'installer
sur l'île de Bréa en pensant que c'était
impossible qu'il y avait pas de maison à
vendre ou qu'il y avait pas de maison à
vendre à moins d'un million et il se
trouve que c'est pas le cas qu'on a
trouvé une maison et qu'on a pu
s'installer l'année dernière sur notre
petit paradis c'est l'île au fleurs donc
donc en fonction des des périodes de
l'année c'est pas elles fleurissent pas
toutes en même temps donc c'est chaque
fois la surprise de se dire ah tiens
c'est vrai j'avais oublié qu'il y avait
ça là il y a beaucoup de maisons de
vieilles maisons en pierre qui sont pas
forcément
très très écolos et du coup
c'était la bonne surprise de découvrir
qu'il y en avait au moins une et qui
nous attendaitage
avec fromage je mets
quoi
ouais en dessous
h
pour moi c'est vital c'est on va droit
dans le mur si on prend pas conscience
que il faut modifier certaines choses et
c'est impossible c'est incontournable en
tout cas je je nimaginez pas alors si
c'était une maison autrement il aurait
fallu effectivement faire des
travaux
investir pour économiser économiser pas
que de l'argent économiser de la de la
planète aussi quoi
la majorité des îles pourrait bientôt
perdre leur charme et devenir
inhabitable c'est en tout cas ce que
pense le chercheur en météorologie
Jean-Louis dufine depuis que l'homme est
fait l'agriculture et cetera depuis 10
1500 ans le climat il a un peu changé
mais pas beaucoup ce qu'on ce que nous
on prévoit comme changement à l'échelle
de 100 ans c'est bien supérieur à tous
ces changement bonsoir à tous un titre
domine l'actualité ce soir c'est la
tempête qui a Bayé la France et qui a
provoqué la mort de 51 personnes selon
un bilan provisoire les secours
continuent actuellement de rechercher H8
personnes qui sont porter disparu quand
il y a une tempête en même temps qu'une
haute maréute ce qui s'est
passé avec la tempête Cynthia et ben il
y a une île par exemple l'île de Ray qui
qui a vraiment souffert très fortement
avec pas mal d'habitations Mo abîmé et
un certain nombre de décès donc ça c'est
très concret sur les deltas il y a
beaucoup de il y a énormément de gens
qui habitent là en fait il y a
énormément de gens qui habite à moins de
quelques mètres de
l'eau si ce dernier site est appelé
pimpul bra c'est que les deux
territoires sont connus des
Français pourtant c'est bien plus bas
Lanec qui accueille le poste de
conversion de l'énergie produite par les
futures
hydroliennes au début les habitants
craignaient des nuisances sonores du au
transformateurs le groupe F a donc dû
convaincre la
population depuis 10 ans Vincent den
Wilks le délégué régional vient
fréquemment travailler avec la maire de
la commune CAF cafézz on commande CAF on
a plus qu'un attachement on a espèce de
de complicité tout simplement parce que
ce projet a vu le jour avec eux c'est
pas notre projet nous EDF tout seul
c'est véritablement le projet de la zone
de de pint Paul bra le deuxième point
c'est que ça ça évite des erreurs
c'est-à-dire que pour le le choix du
site par exemple si nous avions choisi
plutôt les haut de Bréa nous aurions
gêné un petit peu la pêche là nous ne la
gênons
pas en 10 ans deux hydrolienes test ont
été immergés une fois relevé elles ont
été analysées et démantelées afin
d'optimiser les prochaines à la fin de
l'année 2000 15 deux hydroliennes seront
plongé et relié au réseau
national ce sera le premier parc
hydrolien au monde le plateau de laoren
présente plusieurs caractéristiques des
très bon courant de marée qui sont tout
à fait remarquables sans être excessif
on est sur un site d'essès donc il faut
se donner des conditions qui sont
difficiles mais qui ne sont pas
exceptionnelles donc les maximums
observés sont des courants à 6 m second
ce qui est quand même déjà très
important
deuxième point c'est dans une réserve à
crustacé c'est-à-dire que les marins
pêcheurs ne pêchent pas à cet endroit la
zone donc présente un intérêt sur ce
plan-l on ne gêne pas les zones de pêche
et puis c'est à la bonne profondeur 35 m
de fond et nous ne constatons pas ni
d'attraction excessive pour lesertacer
par exemple ni de répulsion particulière
nous n'observons pas non plus
d'obstacles pour le le le le passage des
poissons
et ce que nous observons c'est donc au
fond une neutralité de la machine par
rapport au fond
[Musique]
sous-marin dès l'enfance Yannick Emry
s'était pris de la mer au côté de son
père marin c'est à l'âge de 15 ans qu'il
s'engage dans la marine
marchande suite à un accident de la vie
en 2003 bonjour d il a dû arrêter son
métier de pêcheur pour devenir armateur
d'un bateau de pêche
en parallèle ce breton s'est engagé dans
le projet
d'hydrolienne à travers le comité local
des pêches de l'agnon pin
Paul alors en 85 ils ont voulu implter
une centrale nucléaire à Plec donc
j'étais tout jeune motivé on s'est battu
pour pas qu' a de centrale nucléaire à
Plec quand j'étais à l'école maritime
Audi en 80 81 ils avaient voulu mettre
une centrale à plogof donc j'avais un
petit peu de vécu eDF n'a pas fait la
même démarche qu'en 85 ils ont fait ils
ont été très pédagogues mais aussi nous
ils savaient mon passé il savaiit que
j'avais été un opposant donc ils sont
venus voir un opposant pour qu'struire
quelque chose quelque part Yanb pouvait
pas être opposé à une énergie marine
offshore propre alors qu'en 85 il était
opposé à une centrale nucléaire c'était
un paradoxe néanmoins on n pas donné à
blancin à
EDF en 2007 EDF a inviter les pêcheurs à
visiter un site test en Irlande du Nord
pour les rassurer et les sensibil
par la suite Open hydro la filiale
irlandaise de DCNS qui conduisait le
projet a construit les hydrolienne de
l'énergéticien français beaucoup avent
naviguer dans la marine marchande donc
des infrastructures portuaires des
portiques pour on n'est pas choqué par
ça ici à PUL ça ça a aidé aussi les gars
qui sont revenus d'Irlande ont expliqué
après en assemblée générale ce qu'ils
avaient vu et donc les gars qui n'étit
pas venus ont voté en leur arm et
conscience je crois qu'un vote comme ça
c'était assez inoui 87 % pour le parc
hydrolien à PUL on dit mais attendez les
gars quand tu sur un pétrolier ou un
minéralier qui fait 180000 tonnes en
rate du HAV avec des hélices qui font 18
ou 20 m de de diamètre qui tourne à 60 t
minutes et qui sont à 2 m audessus du
sédiment l'impact il est sûrement plus
contraignant plus plus inquiétant pour
le la biomasse que une hydrolienne et et
de là ah oui c'est vrai effectivement tu
as pas tort y toi mais on a on a aussi
apporté notre vécu et du bon sens ce qui
nous a préoccupé pas tellement inquiété
occupé c'est l'impact sonore par rapport
à la au mifè marin et aussi l'impact du
câble qui va transporter l'électricité
donc c'est de la basse tension par
rapport à la biomasse omomar tourteau
araignée qui peuvent vivre dans le
secteur du passage du câble et donc là
aussi il y a eu des campagnes avec des
sonards embarqués sur des bateaux de
pêche qui ont ont été voir un petit peu
qu'est-ce qu'il y avait comme mamifère
marin dans le coin et tout ça et
l'impact sonore de l'hydrolienne qui a
été mis en situation réelle qui a mis
donc un rapport d'émission sonore et qui
a montré qu'on était largement en
dessous de ce qui pouvait se faire pour
effrayer à MAM
fin convaincu les pêcheurs du comité
attendent désormais l'immersion des deux
géantes encore en
construction pour les observer il faut
se rendre sur la base navale de Brest où
sont assemblé les deux hydroliennes de
pint Paul
bra
Christophe dorignac est le directeur de
ce chantier titanesque comme voyez les
fondations sont arrivés en fond de
bassin nous sommes en train de
simplement faire les travaux de finition
et derrière bien entendu en parallèle
nous allons assembler les différents
composants des turbines juste à côté ici
sur le site de Brest pour ensuite
arriver une phase de connexion qui
consistera à prendre les turbines et
venir les Gruter audessus des fondations
que nous voyons
ici de géantes possède des fondations de
plus de 1000 tonnes mesurant 16 m de
diamètre les deux turbines font quant à
elles 300 tonnes
chacune 250 personnes travaillent sur le
site pour assembler ces monstres d'acier
ce sont des modèles géants qui font
partie des hydroliennes les plus grandes
du monde ces hydroliènes gigantesques
nécessitent 4 mois de construction si
une ferme de plus grande ampleur que
celle du plateau de la aen voit le jour
dans quelques années voilà
à quoi elle pourrait
[Musique]
ressembler participer à un projet de de
cette ampleur c'est bien
entendu ultra passionnant hein nous
sommes à la fois sur des technologies
que nous maîtrisons mais aussi sur du
prototypage ce qui demande une invention
de tous les jours une adaptabilité donc
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
passionnant toutes ces machines sont
encore à l'essai il faudra attendre un
an avant d'avoir un véritable retour
d'expérience les hydroliennes marines
ont un avenir prometteur en France
contrairement à leur cousin fluvial qui
sont voué à
l'export les constructeurs d'hydrolienne
n'ont pas la prétention de résoudre seul
le réchauffement
leur initiative est déjà un pas vers le
changement pour Jean-Louis du freine il
n'est pas trop tard pour agir
l'amplitude du réchauffement sera grand
plus ces changements seront grand et
plus les les conséquences seront
importantes ça c'est sûr aussi donc donc
y a pas baisser les bras aujourd'hui
dans la mesure si on peut réduire tout
ce qu'on peut réduire en terme
d'amplitude du réchauffement ça fera des
changements qui seront moins importants
voilà et donc je préfère dire ça
positivement c'està-dire que tout ce
qu'on met en œuvre pour réduire le
réchauffement aura des conséquences
bénéfiques allez c'est parti Bordeaux
5h30 du matin c'est le grand jour pour
gildaagérard aujourd'hui pas de temps à
perdre hydrotu Energie va enfin émerger
sa
machine sur les chantiers de
l'entreprise
balino la machine doit être posée en
douceur sur le fleuve si l'hydrolienne
est mal
percut alors tout le projet d'hydrotu
énergie pourrait être remis en cause ça
va ça va passer là attention et c'est
avec une certaine émotion que l'équipe
va plonger la machine entièrement
assemblée c'est un projet qui m'a fait
vibrer depuis le le début où c'était
vraiment qu'une idée sur un papier
jusqu'à jusqu'à maintenant où
concrètement on a on a un produit qui
est presque viable quoi il y a des
ajustements à faire mais les choses sont
vraiment très bien très bien en mancher
nous notre objectif c'est de faire des
essais à partir de juillet sur une
période de 6 mois 6 mois au bout duquel
on espère avoir capitalisé suffisamment
d'expérience pour pouvoir faire une
préindustrialisation c'est-à-dire une
hydrolienne numéro 2 on va dire qui sera
préindustriel et derrière aller la
vendre vers les pays en voie de
développement en particulier l'Afrique
puisque c'est notre débouché
principal
[Musique]
allez c'est bon
ok
[Musique]
avant ce qui me stressait c'était euh
possibilité de casse possibilité de
mauvais comportement marin de poids trop
important de
fuite pas trop de stress ça a été les
conditions étaient excellentes en fait
un pas de vent très peu de courant peu
d'embacle je fier ouais je suis super
fier super content en
fait si manipuler une machine de 10 m de
long et de 5 tonnes demande une grande
précaution quand sera-t-il de la machine
wesantine qui mesure 17 m et pèse 450
tonnes des 6h30 du matin aidé par trois
remorqueurs le MV palembank s'est placé
face au port du STIF pour se protéger
des courant lors de l'opération et
attendre l'étale de la
marée pour l'équipe Sabella et quelques
curieux le spectacle est
[Musique]
garanti pour jean-fançois d'Avot c'est
une étape clé de ce projet
pharaonique aujourd'hui c'est une étape
un peu crucial puisque on procède à
l'immersion donc de cette machine de
cette machine qui a été designée né
depuis 2 ans construite depuis 1 an
maintenant euh donc c'est un peu l'heure
de vérité sur le raccordement de de cet
engin à ce réseau
1 j'ai rêvé de tous les problèmes qu'on
a pu avoir et comment il fallait les
résoudre oui sans doute ou et l'instant
l'instant est un peu satisfaisant on est
fier d'abord de de cette machine quand
je dis jeu c'est également toute
l'équipe Sabella il y a
encore 2 mois 3 mois disons 3 mois ce
projet n'existait que sur des visions
numériques
ordinateur il y a 2 mois désormais on la
voit en vraie grandeur sur le port de
Brest et puis aujourd'hui bah elle est
elle est partie à l'au je lui ai fait au
revoir dans un an voilà et en espérant
qu'elle marche bien bien
sûr
[Musique]
les de grues titanesques placent
délicatement l'hydrolienne sous la
surface dans quelques années il se
pourrait que ces machines de toutes
taille sillonn les EAU du monde
entier en attendant DD entame sa des
dans les profondeurs du
[Musique]
from et bientôt du courant jaillira la
lumière
[Musique]